[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ih allen einen schönen guten
Abend den sportlichen Teil der Sendung
übernimmt später wieder Norbert LEH ein
schön guten Abend auch von mir dann
blicken wir jetzt auf die Themen an
diesem
mitittwoch viele Tote nach Explosionen
im
Iran wächst die Sorge vor einer
Eskalation in
Israel Hochwasser weitet sich aus durch
den Dauerregen sind mehrere Bundesländer
betroffen kritisch bleibt die Lage in
Niedersachsen und Spannung in Innsbruck
Andreas Wellinger verliert bei der vier
chanzenournee die Führung hat aber noch
Chancen auf den
Gesamtsieg das Pulverfass Nahost droht
noch gefährlicher zu werden und das hat
auch mit einem Anschlag im Iran zu tun
mit dem wir jetzt in die Sendung starten
über 100 Tote hat es nach zwei schweren
Explosionen gegeben die Tat galt den
Teilnehmern einer Gedenkfeier für Irans
einst mächtigen general suleimani er
koordinierte die militärischen
Auslandseinsätze der Islamischen
Republik mehr von Anna Feist Kerman im
Süden Irans zetausende versammeln sich
zum vierten todestag am Grab des
ehemaligen Anführers der alkutzbrigade
dann hört man zwei
Explosionen offiziell heißt es
mindestens 103 Tote und fast 200
verletzte das Regime spricht von einer
Terrorattacke auf das Grab eines ihrer
wichtigsten Vertreter was steckt
dahinter das war eine Warnung an das
islamische
Regime glaubt nicht dass ihr zu sicher
seid dass ihr zu stark
seid von wem es kommt weiter unklar
versteht nur es ist ein Schlag ins Herz
des regims Kassim suleimani war einer
der wichtigsten Berater von
Revolutionsführer Ali Chamenei sein Erbe
nährt heute den Krieg in Nahost Sulimani
hat die alkutz Brigaden angeführt die
Militäreinheit des Irans im Ausland ihr
Ziel die Eroberung Jerusalems und die
Zerstörung Israels seine Truppen warten
Terrororganisation wie die schiitische
hesbollah im Libanon und die Hamas in
Gaza auf auf Teran Straßen ist der
Schuldige für den Angriff schnell
gefunden verflucht sein sie natürlich
steckt Israel
dahinter sicher werden die Finger nun
erstmal auf Israel zeigen ich halte das
aber für
unwahrscheinlich Israel würde nicht so
wlos
angingreifen schriftlich verspricht am
Abend der iranische Präsident die Täter
dieser feigentat würden bald und für
ihre abscheuliche Tat bestraft
werden der Terroranschlag in Iran und
die Tötung des stellvertretenden
hamasschefs gestern in Beirut zeigen wie
brisant die Situation ist vor dem
Hintergrund beider Ereignisse wurde die
heutige Rede des hisbolla Chefs mit
Spannung erwartet die libanesische
Hisbollah Organisation wird von Iran
unterstützt und steht im Gazakrieg an
der Seite der Hamas Susanne Santina
berichtet die wenigsten im und zweifeln
daran wer hinter dem drohangriff in
berut steckt bei dem gestern unter
anderem der Hamas falarudi getötet wurde
es gibt nach wie vor keine offizielle
Bestätigung Israels aber bezeichnen die
Äußerung des Chefs des israelischen
Geheimdienstes der mossat sieht sich
verpflichtet die Mörder und Planer des
Attentats vom 7 oktober zur Rechenschaft
zu ziehen auch wenn es insgesamt einige
Zeit dauern
wir s alarudi wird für mehrere
Terroranschläge verantwortlich gemacht
und und galt als Nummer 2 neben Hamas
Chef Ismail Hania der bestätigte auch
den Tod von zwei Kommandeuren des
militärischen arms der
Hamas wir bestätigen die Ermordung durch
die zionistische Besatzungsmacht unseres
großen Bruders und kampfesführer alarui
und seiner Brüder es war ein Terrorakt
der die sität des Libanon verletzt hat
eine erneute Feindseligkeit gegen unser
Volk zur Stunde hält hisboller Führer
nasrala eine mit Spannung erwartete Rede
der Hamas sprach er sein Beileid aus und
nannte den Angriff in Beirut eine
Aggression Israels eine konkrete Drohung
wiederholte er bislang
nicht längst hat sich im Norden für
Israel eine neue Front
gebildet und auch die Angehörigen der
immer noch 129 Geiseln sind jetzt in
großer
Sorge Hamas hat gleich nach dem Anschlag
gesagt wir stoppen alle Verhandlungen
natürlich wird das nicht
helfen
im Westjordanland protestierten heute
Hunderte Menschen gegen den
drohenangriff in Beirut die Gefahr eines
Flächenbrandes im Nahen Osten ist sehr
groß guliniai in Kairo hat die Rede des
hisboll Chefs verfolgtlini wie darf man
das einschätzen was nasralla bis jetzt
gesagt
hat die Rede von hassr ging vor wenigen
Minuten zu Ende und er machte eigentlich
keine strategischen keine taktischen
Ankündigungen kann sein dass es mehr
Details gibt in einer zweiten Rede am
Freitag aber die Rede die ich gehört
habe die war größtenteils
propagandistisch und nach innen
gerichtet Hassan nasralla erklärte warum
der Kampf der Hamas der bis heute
weitergeht warum die Anschläge der huti
Rebellen im Roten Meer warum die
Anschläge der proiranischen Milizen in
Irak und Syrien auf US Militärbasen
schon jetzt einen so wörtlich großen
Sieg über Israel bedeuten aber insges
amt scheint Hassan nasrala immer noch
sehr abzuwegen in seinem Vorgehen also
wo fängt die Hilfe für die Hamas in in
Gaza an und wo hört sie auf wo fängt das
nationale Interesse des Libanon an zwei
Dinge könnte das zu Folge haben zum
einen dass die hamasführung im Libanon
sich jetzt nicht mehr öffentlich zeigt
und in den Untergrund geht um die Gefahr
von weiteren israelischen Anschlägen zu
meiden und zum zweiten scheint hanasrall
genau registriert zu haben dass gestern
bei dem Anschlag keine nesischen
Zivilisten ums Leben kamen keine
hisbolla funktionäere ums Leben kamen er
warnte Israel dass falls es dazu käme
sich die Gleichung in diesem Kampf
verändern würde vielen Dank goline und
wir wollen jetzt weitergehen zu
Henriette demesier in Israel an der
Grenze zum Libanon nach der Tötung des
Hamas Kommandeurs in Beirut hatte die
Hisbollah Vergeltung angekündigt
Henriette wie ist die Situation
aktuell allein am Abend hat es zweimal
raketenalarm hier in der Region der
libanesischen Grenze gegeben wir sind in
kirieetma direkt an der libanesischen
Grenze eine Stadt die nach dem 7 Oktober
schon evakuiert wurde es ist
gespenstisch leer hier die Häuser hinter
uns dunkel wir stehen vor einem Bunker
denn sollte es Angriffe geben hat man
genau 10 Sekunden sich in Sicherheit zu
bringen die Armee das wurde schon vor
ein paar Tagen gesagt ist hier verstärkt
worden auch die Luftabwehr über uns
kreist eine Drohne als wir hierher
gefahren sind haben wir auf der Autobahn
LKW gesehen mit Patriot
Abwehrraketen die Lage ist also
angespannt die nächsten Stunden und Tage
werden zeigen wie sich das
weiterentwickelt vielen Dank Henriette
demisier ja mehr zur Rede des hisbolla
Chefs und zur Lage in der OST gleich ab
19:30 Uhr bei den Kollegen von ZDF heute
live auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
und in unserer
App im Machtkampf mit der Justiz hat
Israels Regierungschef Netanyahu einen
weiteren Rückschlag erlitten eine
Gesetzesänderung die seine Amtsenthebung
als Ministerpräsident erschwert hätte
kann erst nach der jetzigen Amtsperiode
in Kraft treten das entschied der
Oberste Gerichtshof Israels mit 6 zu5
Stimmen zur Begründung hieß es das
Gesetz sei eindeutig aus einem
persönlichen Interesse heraus
entstanden jetzt zur deutschen
Hochwassersituation es ist noch kein
Ende in Sicht ganz im Gegenteil in
vielen Regionen gibt es weiter Sorgen
vor steigenden Pegelständen gestern da
sah die Karte mit Warnungen vor großem
Hochwasser noch so aus heute sind
mehrere Gebiete hinzugekommen vor allem
in Sachsen-Anhalt aber auch in Hessen
und in Bayern ein besonders Betroffener
Landkreis ist Bamberg dort beginnt der
Bericht von Clemens
Altmann im bayerischen Oberfranken ist
die itz über die Ufer getreten die
ersten Straßen sind bereits überflutet
die Häuser der Anwohner in Gefahr im
großen Lüder im Landkreis fulder in
Hessen kommt das Wasser über Nacht die
Ortsdurchfahrt steht komplett unter
Wasser auch die Seitenstraßen sind
überflutet das auf einmal dann doch so
stark war und so viel kam und so schnell
kam haben wir nicht mit gerechnet die
Hochwasserlage im Süden sachsenanhals
bleibt weiter angespannt der
landkreismann Südharz hat wegen des
Hochwassers den Katastrophenfall
ausgerufen entlang der Helme sind
hunderte Einsatzkräfte im Dienst um die
Deiche zu verstärken um 7R gen wir uns
die Sirene und seitden sind wir wir
herfahren dann und im Einsatz
Niedersachsen hat alle seine 1,9
Millionen Sandsäcke schon verbraucht
jetzt haben andere Bundesländer weitere
1,5 Millionen zur Verfügung
gestellt Unterstützung auch aus dem
Ausland diese französische
zivilschutzeinheit hat unter anderem
einen mobilen 2 km langen
Hochwasserdeich im Gepäck angesichts der
wahrscheinlich immensen Schäden in den
überschwemmten Gebieten fordert
Niedersachsens Ministerpräsident im
Namen aller 16 Bundesländer eine
Pflichtversicherung als Staat wird man
auf Dauer nicht ständig die Lasten
dieser Naturereignisse tragen können wir
brauchen an dieser Stelle auch die
private Vorsorge für knapp 100 Menschen
in Liliental heiß es weiterwarten wann
sie zurück in ihre Häuser dürfen die
Pegelstände dort sind zwar leicht
gesunken im Nachbarort aber gestiegen
und so wird wie an vielen Orten die Lage
stündlich neu
bewertet Frankreich hilft Deutschland
beim Hochwasser dabei ist unser Nachbar
selbst betroffen starker Regen hat
etliche Flüsse zum Überlaufen gebracht
wie hier im Norden des Landes knapp 200
Menschen mussten ihre Häuser verlassen
es ist bereits das zweite Hochwasser in
halb weniger Wochen Wasser überall auch
in Northampton Großbritannien kämpft
ebenfalls mit den Folgen des Sturms
Henk
2023 war die Arbeitslosigkeit in
Deutschland so niedrig wie selten zuvor
auch wenn die Zahlen im Dezember wie
üblich etwas hochgegangen sind schauen
wir mal drauf insgesamt waren 2
m637 000 Menschen auf Jobsuche 31 000
mehr als im November die Quote lag bei
5,7%. gegenüber dem Vorjahresmonat stieg
die Zahl der Arbeitslosen um
183 000 großes Problem bleibt weiter der
Fachkräftemangel und Unternehmen setzen
deshalb jetzt auch auf geflüchtete
Ukrainer Cornelia
schimens seit 5 Monaten arbeitet der
ukrainische Arzt Paul kudrig bei der
Firma scholp er ist Ukrainer wegen einer
Diabetes kämpft er nicht an der Front
nun will er sich mit Arbeit ein neues
Leben in Deutschland aufbauen man muss
irgendwas machen dann Kopf gesund bleibt
dann korperau gesund bleibt das ist so
paul ist einer von 28 ukrainischen
Mitarbeitern bei scholp die Firma gibt
Hilfestellungen bei allen Fragen rund um
deutsche Formulare Sprache Integration
hier ist man überzeugt viel mehr
Ukrainer würden gern arbeiten wenn die
Hürden in Deutschland gesenkt würden für
die Ukrainer müssten einfach einfachere
Zugänge geschaffen werden teilweise
kommen natürlich die Ukrainer mit ganz
anderen
arbeitsqualifikationen die hier so nicht
bekannt sind nicht so anerkannt sind die
haben ganz anderes Arbeits und
Ausbildungsmodell neben der langwiergen
Anerkennung von Abschlüssen sind es
mangelnde Deutschkenntnisse und fehlende
kitaitapätze die die Ukrainer von Arbeit
Fernhalten von den Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer die jetzt im Lande sind sind
141 000 in Arbeit und jetzt kommen ganz
viele aus den Sprachkursen und können
dann grundständig Deutsch und wir sind
da optimistisch dass es uns dann auch
gelingt sukzessive die Leute in Arbeit
zu bringen bei scholp in Kemnitz will
man nicht warten auf Jobbörsen sucht die
Firma gezielt nach weiteren ukrainischen
Mitarbeitern Deutschlands Kommunen sehen
sich in einer finanziellen Notlage und
fordern mehr Geld von Bund und Ländern
ein Defizit von insgesamt 10 Milliarden
Euro erwartet für 2024 der deutsche
Städte und Gemeindebund dies führe zu
einem erheblichen Sanierungsstau Straßen
und öffentliche Gebäude müssten dringend
saniert werden Schulen und Sportstätten
seien in schlechtem
Zustand nach Argentinien dort gibt es
seit knapp einem Monat einen neuen
Präsidenten zwar den Rechtspopulisten
Javier may der den Menschen eine
Schocktherapie versprochen hatte das
Land steckt in einer schweren Krise die
Inflation liegt bei mehr als
160% 40% der Argentinier Leben in Armut
und jetzt will may den Notstand ausrufen
um den Sozialstaat radikal umzubauen die
angekündigten tiefen Einschnitte lösen
inzwischen Proteste aus und bereiten
vielen große Sorge Christoph
röckerat wer nicht springt ist für may
singen die Demonstranten und alle
springen es ist der Hit der Stunde auf
den Straßen von Buenos Aires immer
wieder gibt es Demonstrationen gegen den
neuen Präsidenten viele Argentinier
fürchten die radikallberalen Reformen
m
wir gehen auf die Straße um Nein zu
sagen zu all diesen Maßnahmen die die
arbeitende Bevölkerung treffen wir haben
heute schon Hunger und
Elend in einem nie daagewesenen Vorgang
hat Präsident m hunderte von
Gesetzesänderungen angeordnet per Dekret
am Parlament vorbei weil er dort keine
Mehrheiten hat in seiner
Neujahrsansprache warnt er die
Institutionen davor ihn
aufzuhalten wenn unser Programm
ausgebremst wird durch die gleichen
Leute die etwas ändern wollen werden wir
nicht verhindern können dass diese Krise
zu einer Katastrophe biblischen Ausmaßes
wird die Proteste nehmen zu mele hat
bereits weitreichende Privatisierungen
Deregulierungen und Lockerungen im
Arbeits und Sozialrecht erlassen und er
will weitergehen auf Jahre den
Ausnahmezustand verhängen kritiker
werfen ihm autoritäre Tendenzen
vor wirtschaftlicher Notstand
finanzieller Notstand rentennotstand
handelsnotstand in den vorliegenden und
gesetzesentwfen gibt es Punkte die dem
Prinzip der gewaltilung
widersprechen schon jetzt hat M das
Demonstrationsrecht eingeschränkt und
die Polizei greift härter durch für Ende
des Monats haben die Gewerkschaften
einen Generalstreik
angekündigt zi Tage nach dem Erdbeben in
Japan ist die Zahl der Toten auf 73
gestiegen und die Suche nach
Überlebenden kommt nicht richtig voran
denn die betroffene Halbinsel noto liegt
ziemlich abgelegen für die Rettungsteams
sind die wenigen Straßen dorthin teils
unpassierbar geworden erst recht die
kleinen Wege in die Bergregionen auch da
könnten noch Menschen unter Trümmern
eingeschlossen sein und die Zeit wird
knapp sie rechtseitig zu finden
Elisabeth
Schmidt ohnmächtig muss dieser Mann mit
ansehen wie Rettungskräfte seine Frau
Tod aus dem Haus tragen Suu im Norden
der vom Erdbeben besonders stark
betroffenen Halbinsel die Feuer wer hat
aufgehört die Notrufe zu zähen noch
immer Liegen Menschen lebendig unter
Trümmern
begraben mehr als zwei Tage sind seit
dem Erdbeben vergangen die Rettung der
Opfer ist ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit
wir haben jetzt einen kritischen Punkt
erreicht auf notto sind weite Teile nach
wie vor von der Außenwelt abgeschnitten
in den Notunterkünften wird die Lage
immer
verzweifelter
ich bin barfuß hierher geflüchtet ich
konnte entkommen aber hier gibt es kaum
Wasser keine Decken es ist so kalt in
den drei Tagen jetzt habe ich nur einen
einzigen Becher Wasser getrunken immer
nur einen winzigen
Schluck Generatoren fallen aus Heizung
Telefon Internet gibt es viel Orts nicht
mehr wie schwer es ist in die
verwüsteten Regionen zu gelangen
schildert ein Journalist auf dem Weg
nach
wajima
Tunnel sind eingestürzt Brücken
zusammengebrochen ein Erdrutsch nach dem
anderen Risse in der Straße wir kommen
nicht in die Siedlung rein wir können
nur auf die Streitkräfte
hoffen die sollen jetzt von 1000 auf
2000 aufgestockt werden und Hilfsgüter
per Helikopter in die abgeschnittenen
Gebiete bringen mittlerweile regnet es
der Wetterdienst waren vor weiteren
Schlammlawinen Rettungsarbeiten unter
extrem
Bedingungen
nach dem Zusammenstoß gestern auf dem
Flughafen in Tokio gibt es erste
Erkenntnisse zur Unglücksursache die
Kollision des Passagierflugzeugs mit der
Maschine der Küstenwache war offenbar
Folge eines menschlichen Versagens nach
Behördenangaben hatte der Tauer der
kleineren Maschine keine Erlaubnis
gegeben auf die ST und Landebahn zu
fahren im Kleinflugzeug kamen fünf
Besatzungsmitglieder ums Leben aus dem
Passagierflugzeug konnten sich alle 379
Menschen retten
jetzt z vier schanzenournee Norbert
dritte Station ist innsbrurg und das
Duell um den gesamtseg das bleibt ja
super spannend ja allerdings weil
Andreas Wellinger nach seiner schwachen
Leistung gestern in der Quali heute nun
lieferte und auf Rang 5 sprang sein
erxstter Rivale rioyo kobayyashi wurde
Zweiter und liegt jetzt in der
Gesamtwertung ganz knapp vor
Wellinger im ersten Durchgang hat
Andreas Wellinger mit 132 m ein
Statement
gesetzt dann der zweite Sprung zu kurz
Absprung nicht getroffen der Wind
ungünstig nur
126,5 m Wellinger entäuscht aber er
bekommt Pluspunkte für die
Windverhältnisse und lächelt dann doch
noch Podest verpasst aber Platz 5 ja wir
haben gewusst dass es bisschen der
windlotterie wir die war jetzt nicht
unbedingt der glücklichste im zweiten
aber vom Sprung selber von der Energie
vom Fluss war der schon ziemlich gut die
Chance auf den Gesamtsieg hat er sich
bewahrt sein größter Konkurrent rioyo
Kobayashi schnappt sich zwar die Führung
in der turnneewewertung liegt aber nur
4,8 Punkte vor Wellinger das dritte
springen in Innsbruck gewonnen hat der
Österreicher Jan
hör das deutsche Tennisteam mit Angeli
herber und Alexander SEV ist beim United
Cup in Sydney als bester Gruppen zweiter
doch noch ins Viertelfinale eingezogen
am Freitag gegt es gegen das griechische
Team ja und er steht jetzt tatsächlich
im Finale Luke Littler ganze 16 Jahre
alt er kann heute ab die Sensation in
London perfekt machen und jüngster
Weltmeister in der Darts Geschichte
werden er ist die sportüberraschung des
noch jungen Jahres Luke ller bei der
ersten WM gleich im Finale kontrahendr
crross spielt gestern eines seiner
besten Matches führt 1:0 nach setzen und
muss sich ller doch geschlagen geben der
16 Jahre alte darz Wunderknabe
nervenstark eiskalt und mit fast 50%
doppelquote 6:2 am Ende das Match macht
der zu mit D ins lie Feld sein Gegner im
Finale heißt heute Luke humfries ein
Sieg fehlt Luke genannte Nuke jetzt noch
zur
Krönung ja ich weiß was ich heute
angucke dann vielen Dank Norbert gerne
und wenn Sie das nächste Mal über
Winterkälte klagen dann sollten Sie sich
an folgende Bilder erinnern in Schweden
ganz hoch im Norden da sind die
Temperaturen ganz tief im Keller alles
wie Schock gefroren -
43,6° kalt
kälter Krieg oder oder so ähnlich heißt
der Ort mit diesem frostrekord nur vor
25 Jahren war es im Land noch kälter ja
was hilft schützende Kleidung und
irgendwie immer in Bewegung bleiben
fehlen jetzt noch die Zahlen vom
Mittwochslotto hier sind sie 14 25 28 32
36 49 und die Superzahl lautet 4 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf
lotto.zf.de und auf der ZF Textseite
Unwetterwarnungen des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes vor ergiebigem Dauerregen
laufen zum Teil noch bis Freitag und
betreffen vor allem die Mittelgebirge
mehr dazu gleich von Katja horneffer das
heute journal das sehen Sie um
21:45 Uhr mit Christian siwas das war's
von uns vielen Dank fürs Interesse und
gerne bis morgen W
[Musik]
sie
guten Abend kaum ist das Tief Anneli
morgen nach Osten abgezogen kommt schon
gleich das Tief Brigitta hinterher das
sind keine guten Aussichten für die
hochwasserregionen in Schleswig-Holstein
in Hamburg in Niedersachsen in
SachsenAnhalt Thüringen Bayern und in
Nordrhein-Westfalen denn es gibt weitere
stauniederschläge heute Nacht hier vor
allen Dingen im Sauerland im Südwesten
kann es auch mal für Blitz und Donner
reichen im Norden mischen sich unter den
Regen auch einige schneefl denn dort
sinken die Temperaturen bis 0° sonst
liegen die nachtwerte bei 8 bis 3° und
morgen wird es in Schleswig-Holstein
kaum milder da liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen um 1° sonst werden 3
bis 11° erreicht und so bleibt es morgen
bei diesem Schneeregen im Nordosten
sonst ist es meist bedeckt stark bewrken
es gibt nach wie vor kräftige Regenfälle
besonders in den Mittelgebirgen am
Nachmittag setzt sich dann im Südwesten
häufiger auch mal die Sonne durch ja und
am Freitag kann es dann hier in
Norddeutschland durchaus für einige
Zentimeter Schnee reichen dann wird's
auch glatt auf den Straßen die gute
Nachricht für die Hochwassergebiete ist
dann dass der Regen nachlässt und es von
Norden merklich kälter wird am Sonntag
bei -5 bis + 2° guten Abend